so what do you remember about scoring
your first number one single then do you
have a story about that
uh if it's in america um or ca no ca can
canada probably would have been sing or
shape of you or something i don't know
maybe think out loud in england it was
sing
and uh i was playing a festival in
holland and i'd been on an all-night
bender with like four of my friends and
we'd been out a club until like four
o'clock in the morning and we were
really really feeling a bit ropey
heading to this festival to play and i
was in the car with my best friend nick
and um
yeah got a text and said you're you're
number one it was my very very first
number one um
yeah it's been it's amazing yeah it's
been good england's england's been good
to me in terms of in terms of number
ones england's like my
it's my home so i feel like the most
success is what i've had here love it in
the song first times you talk about
one of the things that you'll never
forget is your greatest achievement your
engagement so on a scale of one to ten
how much of a romantic are you
um like what's a date night look are you
are you good
do you know i think because we go to a
lot of pubs for our date night and and
we you know we'll have like
burger and chips or fish and chips or
bangers a mash or whatever with a bit
with a with a beer and i don't think
it's about the
spot that you go to because we could go
to a dollar slice pizza place but if i'm
on my phone for the entire time that's
not a good evening so yeah i think
whatever happens whether it's whether
it's birthdays valentine's day is date
night the most romantic you can be is
present and listen and ask questions and
i found it i find this even more being
apparent is
we find when we're at home all we talk
about is lyra lyra's done this like oh
what if she's doing this laura's done
this lowe's done that and one of our
mates said make sure you go out once a
week on a date night and never talk
about your kid for two hours and you
just you go how are you and that was the
best advice we ever got because we go
and
we essentially get to fancy each other
again you you know you sit you sit down
and you go hello you know yeah exactly
and
and that's a that's a rare thing for i
you know i feel like a dad and cherry
feels like a mum but then we feel like
we're 22 again when we go out on on date
night so i think it's a really important
thing so i would say romance is being
present and listening yeah we went on a
date the other night because it's our
13th wedding anniversary together
two kids thank you and i was walking
around shopping and i kept saying well
jackson would like that nyla would like
that and he said can you just stop
talking about our kids it's about us
it's a good it's a good rule to have
it's a good because because we find
ourselves slipping into it too and then
the other one whoever is slipping into
it the other one goes
no not tonight not tonight
and it's good it's good it really is no
it's true listen when i listen to music
i see the music videos immediately in my
head so when i was sitting and i was
listening to your album
um leave your life
felt to me like i saw a mother and a son
or a child and their journey together
what do you see when you see that song
so do you need someone to direct your
videos or come up with the concepts just
saying
um so that's that song is my favorite
song on the album and that song's the
one that means the most to me it's uh um
again speaking about my friend uh he
passed away he had a daughter and i
spoke to his daughter on the day of his
funeral and she said he always told me
he loved me after every single
conversation he said i love you so the
last thing that he ever said to me was i
love you
and i was because i do that anyway i do
that whenever i get a plane i text
chairs and i say i love you or text my
parents i make i just make sure people
know but my daughter will never know
because she can't speak or understand or
have memory yet and people will just
tell her
hey by the way your dad loves you
imagine if i if i died tomorrow they'd
go your dad loved you and she'd be like
how do i know this and i wanted to make
a song that basically said
that you know if i forget to say goodbye
before i catch a plane will you know the
way that i feel when i'm away and the
the lyrics in the chorus uh um
yeah i'll i'll i'll never leave your
life like i'll i'll always be there even
at the times of miles away i'm always by
your side i'm like tearing up i was
falling when i was listening to that
song because i was laying down and i had
tears streaming down the side of my face
that's good
but this is what i love about music and
this is what i like i
i get emotional writing these songs and
like i i really want this album you know
i feel like people listen to bad habits
and they go oh party tune okay that's
what the album's gonna be and they
listen to shivers and probably think the
same thing but there's so much on this
album that is more
it's below the surface level you know
yeah it takes you to so many different
places each time like i said it felt
like a little movie as i was listening
to each song it was spectacular thank
you i really i really appreciate it i
mean i've really
taken a long time making this and i'm so
proud of it how long did it take you
well i say four years because i started
it on the divide tour i started in june
2017 but like honestly hardcore
about a year but in that year it was
marriage baby
death 30 and so all of that informed the
record but first times i wrote in 2018
um
the
love and slow motion i lived in wrote in
2018 shivers was 2019 but in terms of
like leave your life visiting hours bad
habits um
[Music]
what was the other one stop the rain
collide tides they all kind of came in
one massive
wave of songs right so was it hard to
birth an album like this when you said
you know baby wedding loss of a friend
is it harder to birth an album like this
with so much emotion in those three
areas
and putting it out to the world than
other albums
yeah because i think i think
no matter what i say if it doesn't have
the connection with the people and i'm
not talking about breaking records like
i've broken records i don't need to
break records again i'm talking about
connection with people what you said
when you said i listened to that song
and it made me cry and it made me think
of all these things if i don't have that
with people i don't think that i've made
a great album i have to make an album
that people
really
connect with and i don't really give a
[ __ ] at the end of the day whether it's
shape of you or whether it's bad habits
like those songs
for me shape of you exists so people
listen to perfect and for me bad habits
bad habits exists so people listen to
visit visiting hours and i can't just
release perfect and i just can't like
just release visiting hours i find that
with pop music nowadays it's the
you give this to get this and i've i
i love having songs on the radio
but a song like leave your life doesn't
get played on the radio if i haven't had
bad habits shivers and overpass graffiti
before it and i just that's just the way
i like doing it and um
yeah i really want people to buy this
album or stream this album or borrow
this album off a friend or whatever
listen to it on on on youtube and i want
them to have some sort of emotional
connection with it yeah it's a big life
experience in this album that's for sure
for sure and i think and i i don't think
it's it's it's not a discrimination
discriminant it doesn't discriminate
it's not like i'm 30 therefore if you're
18 you won't get this i think what's
interesting about something like grief
is like when grief happened to me i
turned into an adult but grief turns
anyone into an adult you can be 14 and
go through grief and then you are
instantly an adult because it's real
life that's happening to you and i i
want it to it's not an album that only
30 year olds can relate to i want it to
be an album that across the board people
can be like i get this feeling and i get
this feeling too yeah it's like a loss
of innocence right that just is gone
when that happens precisely yeah
precisely and i i'm so lucky that i'm 30
and that's the first time it's happened
to me you know i'm i'm very fortunate
because of that but
um it doesn't make it any less real
absolutely
um joker and the queen another music
video i saw a disney movie i feel like
disney needs to call that's what i saw
like i saw zendaya in the music video i
know you've had lots of celebrities
in your music videos and things like
that do you have someone in mind for
videos as you go along
uh
i don't really know what to do for that
for that for that video part part of me
i've got i've got all the other videos
mapped out and part of me thinks i've
used my um
my puppet for uh sing i use my puppet
for happier and there isn't a song on
this album that i've used the puppet for
and i feel like
it might it might be this one it might
be this one or it might i might have to
but i feel like the puppet always has to
make an appearance but i don't i don't
know if
it suits this song um originally i
wanted to we actually got in touch with
buckingham palace and i wanted to um get
an orchestra in the gardens of
buckingham palace and play it live but
it's not as easy as it is well actually
it doesn't even sound easy but i just
thought it would be a good
uh video to do you know actually just
call and be like hi it's dead
orchestra
no because there's so it's it's because
it's it's commercial like you can't
commercialize buckingham palace you
can't then make a music video and then
sell that music video with the
buckingham palace name in it or
something like that you know i might be
able to do it at another castle
somewhere but it i just thought it would
be a good idea to do it at buckingham
palace but it's i don't think it's
possible we've got a nice castle here in
toronto called casa loma i got married
there i can make a call for you easy did
a queen ever live there
i don't think that
sorry
amazing
you